have you ever cooked a chicken that was
so dry was barely edible or served a
turkey at Thanksgiving that was so
parched your guest wanted to offer it a
drink well that's why we created the
turbo trusser the turbo trusser is a
rapid trusting device used when cooking
whole chickens and turkeys I give you an
offer you have to make a decision young
[Music]
people baby this is fantastic
this inexpensive really effective
fantastic cooking utensil every time you
make a turkey it's going to be
absolutely perfect what a great device
that's the best Shark Tank turkey I've
ever had I have one of my companies
called turbo trusser we sell a lot of
trusters right
[Music]
now that song lets you know it is that
time the day you know our next shark our
next guest as one of the Sharks on the
hit ABC show shark tank but what you
might not know is that he also happens
to know his way around the kitchen and
it's right and today he's going to show
us how to make a winter winner chicken
dinner please welcome Kevin o AKA Chef
one thank you so much you know but check
out this headgear I'd love the headgear
I'm honoring the chicken I want to be
one with the bird we're actually going
to be working with the chicken today
chicken is one of the best protein
values in America if you buy the whole
bird most people say oh I'm just going
to get the legs just going to get half
no by the whole bird I'm going to show
you how to cook it all right what are we
doing today first thing is we're going
to the Mediterranean the great
ingredients in the Mediterranean lemons
no question about it garlic and of
course you want lemon juice this is
about half a lemon right here I'm going
to make a paste we're going to put on
the chicken you're going to help me
ready sir we're going to grind a little
garlic with a little lemon zest this is
seasoning here some people call it zatar
here's some pepper and you just grind
this up and that's grind
it crush it and you end up with a
you end up with a past like that it's
hard to do but this is the paste all
right when you're finished with it now
what you want to do with this paste is
you know that song I'm getting you under
my skin well you got to get this under
the skin of this chicken now I don't use
gloves it's okay for you to do it look
let me give the first pinch cuz that's
where the flavor gets in the pinch and
push pinch and push and rub get in there
get in there and rub it sounds like an
exercise class pinch and push and rub
got to step
okay perfect I like this listen you a
job with me as an assistant Chef I'll
come work with
you so you do you also want to rub it
there because that's how you're going to
get the crispe you see that feel be
tactile with the bird tactile with the
bird be one with the bird I don't fear
the bird you got the gloves on Chefs
don't mind that beautiful Aroma and it's
good for your skin olive oil is
fantastic Dr J loves we've got to
actually stuff this we're going to go
next you ready to push you're going to
put in half a clove of garlic inside the
bird birs you know where the garlic or
the right there right there and he go o
one more one more one more one more okay
he go stick a couple of lemons right in
there that's it lemon slices shove them
up all right that's too much now here's
the secret we're all going to learn
today the reason a bird dries out
particularly the white meat is it all
the juices leak when it's cooking for an
hour at 375 the way to stop that from
happening used to be traditionally
trussing it that you take some twine and
you wrap it around the legs and then you
try and wrap the wings to keep it close
to the body yeah yeah you like however
what invariably happens is the legs stay
trust but the wing the the string Burns
off and they open up and all the juice
flows that's why we saw this on Shark
Tank last year called the turbo trusser
this trusser actually gets the bird into
a harness that pushes it all into a big
ball of chicken and Cooks it absolutely
perfect if you have employees you need
to check out the ERC program Chef
wonderful why Mr Wonderful because it's
it's cash flow that you don't have to
pay back good to know this guy's so
smart and so handsome go to wonder
trust.com to see if you're eligible see
that oh wow and then you don't have to
single-handedly try to trust you that's
why the truss is so great also for
turkeys and you hook it into the wing
like this and now you're getting
basically the wing stuck right to the
bird all right like here's handcuffs on
the chicken here's what it looks like
here's what it looks like that's amazing
isn't that amazing one big unit as I
like to say don't fuss it just truss it
that's how you do it don't fuss it just
realest so many of these kitchen
utensils over the years on Shark Tank
you never get used again not this one
it's in my kitchen I use it for every
bird I make turkey and chicken okay you
go to Turbo trust.com or Amazon the real
test is to taste it you know yes let me
do this because it's always the white
meat let me cut a piece off the white
meat this is where you test if you're
going to get that juiciness that you
really really want ready just that white
meat by itself that lemon zest really
you can taste adds to the flavor here
how it goes ready let's tast it oh I
already ate mine oh wow
oh it is so also full outfit shot can we
please show his full outfit that's what
I'm talking about that is what I'm
talking about you never taste chicken
like that W this is fantastic don't you
so this is a Mediterranean dish it is
all of these flavors the olive oil the
lemon lemon is one of the great great
flavors of the Mediterranean you can
actually put it right on the
bird and it's good ridiculous that's
ridiculous wonderful thank you isn't
this the way to go yes thank you so much
and if you want to get this recipe you
can head to good morning am.com food or
you can scan that QR code that's right
there on your screen right now don't
fuss it just trust it just trust it